in the last video we learned that an
ellipse can be defined as the locus of
all points where the sum of the distance
is just two special points called foci
let me draw this all out so that's my
x-axis the sum of the distance to these
two special points called focuses or
foci is a constant so if this is my
ellipse
let me draw it out
oh that looks about
i want it to be right around
and that looks about right it's centered
at the origin doesn't have to be but for
for our purposes let's make it centered
at the origin if this is one focus point
right here
and this is the other focus point
this ellipse
could be defined as a set of all points
or the locus of all points
where if i take
the distance of any one of these points
that that exist on the ellipse and take
the distance to each of the locuses
sorry each of the focuses so if i take
that nope i don't want to do that
if i take that distance
and add it
to
this distance
so let's call those
i don't know let's call this d1
d nope too thick
let's call that
d
one this is d2 that that's going to be
equal to a constant number along the
whole ellipse so if i take a random
let's say another point along the lips
say take this point right here
and if i were to sum
this distance if i were to sum
this distance to
that distance so let's call this
let's call this right here
d3 this is d4 the sums of these
distances to the focus along this
ellipse are going to be a constant so in
this case d2 plus d1 this plus that is
going to be equal to
d3 plus d4
d3 plus d4 and this would be true
wherever you go along the whole ellipse
and we learned in the last video that
this quantity is actually going to be
equal to 2a where a is the distance the
semi-major radius if this is the formula
for the ellipse this is where the a
comes from x squared over a squared plus
y squared over v squared is equal to
one
and we learned that the focus the focal
distance or the distance from the center
of ellipse of the ellipse which is this
distance right here
that focal distance is just the square
root of the difference of these two
numbers so it's just so we could call if
this is the focal distance
from here to here
it's just equal to
the square root
of
if a is larger then than would be a
squared minus b squared which is the
case in this ellipse if we have a
vertical ellipse and i really didn't
cover it in the last video but let me
just show you what it would look like
let's say that
the ellipse looks something like this
let me see all right
i'll use blue
let's say the ellipse look like
that
in this case
our our semi-major radius is now in the
y direction
so this is
so this is b
this is a and in this case b is greater
than a
right because
the the the ellipse is tall and skinny
and in this case the focuses are going
to all well they're always going to lie
along the major axis in this case the
major axis is the vertical axis so the
focus is are going to sit
here
and here
and in this case the focal lengths are
going to be
vertical down from the origin and
vertical up from the origin
and we get
instead of it being a squared minus b
squared now since b is larger than a the
focal length which is this
the focal length is going to be equal to
v squared minus a squared
fair enough
now i did all of that to kind of compare
it to what we're going to cover in this
video which is the focus point or the
foci of a hyperbola and a hyperbola it's
it's very close to an ellipse i mean you
could you could probably guess that
because if this is an equation of an
ellipse
this is the equation of a hyperbola x
squared over a squared
minus y squared over b squared is equal
to one or we could switch these around
where the minus is in front of the x
instead of the y and we could cover that
in a second but this hyperbola looks
something like
this let me see if i can draw it
let's see if i draw the axes
and i want to draw the asymptotes you
could prove it you could look at the
some of the previous videos but the
asymptotes for this hyperbola are going
to be y
is equal to plus or minus v over a
x
it's going to look
i'll just draw them as kind of
tilted lines
so it would look something like
that something like
nope
i want to make it
something like that those would be the
asp because this one's centered at the
origin because it's not it hasn't been
shifted
and then that's those two lines right
there
and then this is what i call kind of a
horizontal hyperbola the way you can
think about that is
well if you if you solve for y you'll
see that you're always going to be a
little bit lower than the asymptote the
other option is say okay can x or y
equals zero well if y is equal to zero
that puts us along the x axis
right and you get x squared over a
squared is equal to one or x
so if y is equal to zero you get x
squared over a squared is equal to one
which means that x
squared is equal to a squared
which means that x is equal to plus or
minus a so the points
a comma zero so this is the point a
comma 0
and the point minus a
minus a comma 0 are both on this
hyperbola and since they have to kind of
be contained by these asymptotes never
go through it you know that this is
going to be a a hyperbola that opens to
the left and the right so it'll look
something like this
oop
let me use this color
so it'll look something this is the hard
part so it'll get closer and closer on
that side and then
kind of view this as one of the vertexes
or vertices of the hyperbola
well it'll go like that
or this distance and notice the the
similarity here with the ellipse this
distance right here let me do it in a
more vibrant color this distance right
here
between these two
i guess you could kind of the elbows of
the two ellipses that distance right
there this is a
and this is also
a so you have a 2a distance which is
very similar
to this situation where this distance
is a
and this distance is a so your distance
between the two left and right points in
a horizontal ellipse is the same as the
distance between the two left and right
points on a hyperbola it's just the
hyperbola opens outward while the
ellipse opens inward fair enough but the
whole point of this video is to discuss
foci and you might have guessed and i
did touch on it in the last video that
hyperbola also have foci but they open
they're going to be to the right and the
left of these two points so this is a
let me do them let me do them in a
bright color because i want you to see
them
let's say that those two are those are
the two foci and a hyperbola this is and
notice the difference an ellipse
one of the definitions of an ellipse was
the locus of all points or the set of
all points where the distance from each
of those points the sum of the distance
from each of those points to the two
foci is a constant
now the definition
of a hyperbola one of the definitions of
a hyperbola can be the locus of all
points
where you take the the difference not
the sum you take the difference of the
distances
between the two foci
so let me write that down so this is
if this is d1
and this is
d2
so you have a situation and we want to
take we could take the absolute value of
the difference because they might be
they might at some points d1 will be
longer than d2 if you're on this curve
if you're on this curve d1 will be
shorter than d2
so d1
minus d2 the absolute value is going to
be equal to constant in the ellipse
situation d1 plus d2 was a constant so
they're very closely related you're in
the ellipse you're taking the sum of the
distances to the focus points and and
saying it's a constant and a hyperbola
you're taking the difference of the
distances to the focus points and saying
that's a constant so this number right
here is going to be the exact same thing
as if i took a point right here
and i'm picking these points arbitrarily
as long as they're on the hyperbola and
if i call these
two points
let's call these d3
and d4
the difference between d1 and d2 is the
same thing as the the distance the
difference between
d3
minus d4 this is going to be a constant
the entire way around the ellipse
and so the next question is well what
what is this constant going to be equal
to and this is where it's it's useful to
find a point where it's where you can
kind of get the intuition and we did it
with the ellipses where we said
oh if we take these points
we used logic in the last video to say
oh the distance between the sum of the
distance between this
and this
that sum
is going to be equal to
we saw is going to be equal to 2a or the
distance of the semi-major axis right
because this distance was the same as
this distance so this plus this is the
same thing as this plus that which is 2a
right so the entire time the constants
the sum of the distances to the two foci
was equal to 2a
now in the hyperbola what is the
difference of the distances to the two
foci
so let's take this point right here on
the hyperbola
and we're saying so what is
what is let me do a good color what is
the magenta distance
that's the distance to that foci
minus
minus this or let me pick another color
minus this i know light blue distance
this magenta distance minus this light
blue distance so we can make a very
simple similar argument that we made in
the ellipse situation
this light blue distance is the same
this the distance from this vertex or
from this i guess you know this left
most point of this rightward opening
hyperbola to this focus is the same as
this distance
because the hyperbola is symmetric
around the origin and or the focal
length is the same on either side of the
center of the hyperbola depending on how
many view it but i think that's a
that that's not too much of a stretch of
a statement for you to for you to accept
so if this distance is the same as this
distance
then the magenta distance
minus this blue distance is going to be
equal to
this green distance
right and this green distance is what
that's 2a we saw that at the beginning
of this video so this once again is also
equal
to 2a
anyway i'll leave you there right now
actually well
let's actually just do one problem just
because i like to make one concrete
because i told you at the beginning that
if you wanted to find let's say the
so what if you have an ellipse
so if you this is an ellipse x squared
over a squared plus
y squared over b squared is equal to one
we learned that the let's go for b
squared this is an ellipse
we learned that the focal length is
equal to
the square root of a squared minus b
squared now for a hyperbola you you kind
of see that there's a very close
relation between the ellipse and the
hyperbola this is kind of a fun thing to
ponder about you know a a hyperbolas
equation looks like
this
x squared over a squared minus y squared
over b squared or it could be y squared
over b squared minus x squared over a
squared is equal to 1. it turns out and
i'll prove this to you in the next video
it's a little it's a bit of a hairy math
problem that the focal length of a
hyperbola
is equal to the square root of the sum
of these two numbers is equal to the sum
of a squared plus b squared
so if i were to give you so notice the
difference it's just a difference in
sign you're taking the difference of
those kind of two denominators and now
you're taking the sum of the two
denominators so if i were to give you
the following hyperbola x squared
x squared over 9
plus y squared
over 16 is equal to
one
well the first thing you do is that
never well we could just figure out the
focal length just by plugging into the
formula the focal length
is equal to the square root of a squared
plus b squared this is a squared right a
is three
b is four so nine plus 16 is 25
which is equal to five and so if we were
to graph this
let me see
so that's my y-axis
that's my x-axis it's and the focal
length is the distance to the in this
case to the left and the right of the
origin if it was kind of an up and down
opening hyperbola would be above and
below the origin so this is a this is a
oh sorry this should this shouldn't be a
plus
we're doing it with a hyperbola that
should be a minus don't want to confuse
you what i had written before with a
plus i would have been an ellipse a
minus is a hyperbola
so the two asymptotes this is centered
at the origin it hasn't been shifted are
going to be 16 over 9 so it's going to
be fairly steep asymptotes it's going to
look something like
that
and that
those are the two asymptotes
the two vertex points are at two
times a a is three right
a squared is equal to nine b squared is
equal to sixteen
so this is the center so the two vertex
points this is three
minus three and then the focal points
are going to be at
par from the center five to the right so
it's going to be right here so that's
five comma zero
so it's five comma zero
and minus five comma zero this is minus
three and this is three so if we were to
graph it it would look something like
this
there you go
and if you were to take
an arbitrary point on that hyperbola and
take this distance
and subtract that from that distance
that will be a constant number that
would be exactly equal to 2a or exactly
equal to 6 in this particular example
anyway hopefully i didn't confuse you
too much with that little sign error
near the end of the video but in the
next video i'll prove to you this
formula which is a little bit of a hairy
algebra but it's fun to do regardless